wir machen heute berger bürger aus
influenza produkten
[Musik]
freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video ich habe einiges vorbereitet ihr
seht hier eine ausweitung im fenster
produkten erinnert euch ja vielleicht an
meine ein tag von influenza produkten
leben videos da habe ich schon
festgestellt dass das alles relativ nice
schmeckt und ich dachte mir wie nice
kann es schmecken wenn man alles
zusammen tut deshalb haben wir hier
kapital pizza wir haben lukas podolski
dönerfleisch kräftig spiels von rita
rocks chips und ein neuzugang eine
barbecue sauce von den sessel brothers
und mit diesem ganzen zutaten machen wir
einen burger und ihr fragt euch moment
mal bürger die haben doch eigentlich
brötchen wir machen aus der capital
pizza mit diesem frischen pizza decken
wir haben schien sie kraft pizza burger
bahn das fängt alles schon nach
herzversagen aber ich glaube es wird
verdammt verdammt lecker und um den
burger perfekt zu machen brauchen wir
natürlich noch ein paar schnittstellen
die das ganze verbinden wir haben hier
rucola schießt rings ich komme gleich
dazu warum wir diese brauchen eine
fleischtomate peter käser minister
petersilie burke und frischen joghurt
wirklich leute das wird ein genuss ihr
merkt schon diese ganzen sachen sind
relativ würzig orientalisch inspiriert
und da konnten wir perfekt dagegen ich
sag euch ehrlich das wird nicht so ein
video wir werfen als zu sagen dass
wirklich geil was wir heute machen und
deshalb fangen wir jetzt natürlich habe
ich zwei pizzen wohl wir haben eine
unterseite und eine oberseite vom burger
und wir schnappen uns jetzt einfach
unsere karten spitze wir brauchen
natürlich einheitlichkeit deshalb habe
ich hier einen untersetzer einfach
liegen in der mitte drauf und leute ich
glaube ich muss niemandem erklären dass
wir den rest sei nicht wegwerfen dann
dass wir uns das einfach sein können
werden unterteller drauf damit die schön
einheitlich sind die ober und unterseite
und wir schneiden jetzt erstmal
[Musik]
diese kraft zeit und ihr seht ich habe
dafür wie gesagt diese die sticks geholt
hat einen ganz bestimmten grund
eigentlich sind die nur schmidt fester
mozzarella und wir können sie perfekt
funktionieren um eben eine leckere gysi
crust außen zu bekommen und wir gucken
uns erst mal den teig an den dinge
bekommen haben sie fast ein bisschen
vollkorn mäßig aus sollte aber ganz
normaler pizzateig sein wenn ihr das
nachmachen volt ganz egal was für einen
wir brauchen jetzt quasi einen langen
streifen pizzateig lappen jetzt quasi
den zusätzlichen pizzateig einmal um den
rand und um die piigs wir nehmen jetzt
also quasi so ein stück und schneiden
das einmal zu einer spirale
wir müssen neue schnitttechniken heute
anwenden dafür vierbauch ist aber
erstmal ein weiteres blatt backpapier
und jetzt nehmen wir uns hier unseren
pizzateig quasi sein damit wird einmal
außen herum geben könnt schon ein gutes
stück sondern man so gar nicht mal so
leicht was ich hier schnell zieht jetzt
schnappen wir uns unsere pizza das sieht
jetzt ein bisschen unbeholfen aus und
legen liegt hinab über den rand wir
gucken dass der überall darunter kommt
allen seiten und am ende wieder zusammen
wir haben jetzt so einen schönen ring
den blick auf unser neues backpapier und
dann ziehen wir das hier so schön ab
deshalb formt sich schnell habe ich beim
ersten gemerkt dass es vorsichtig und
wir schnappen uns die zweite pizza habe
unten noch eine kleine lücke
reingeschnitten damit wir das
zusammenfügen können und dann leicht ist
so muss das aussehen jetzt kommen wir zu
unserem käse ihr könnt euch denke ich
mache das natürlich auch zum ersten mal
gerade aber wir schneiden uns jetzt ein
paar schöne kleine stücke von unseren
ski stick starten und die platzieren wir
dann direkt an der kruste rundherum mit
ein bisschen abstand logischerweise
verlaufen die auch noch mit dem rest von
teig rollen wir einfach aus dem
schneiden streifen daraus dann nehmen
wir uns hier so ein streifen und legen
den ebenfalls überlappend auf unseren
pizza rand oben drauf und dann einfach
unteren und oberen pizzateig gut
zusammendrücken wichtig keine lücken
lassen weil logischerweise läuft euch
der käse sonst einfach auf das backblech
und das wollen wir natürlich nicht
solche stellen einfach zusammenkneifen
und ihr seht schon dann ist alles schön
geschlossen
und jetzt nehmen wir uns unsere pizzen
und packen sie in den ofen bis 11 12
minuten wird wahrscheinlich bisschen
länger dauern als wenn man das ganz
normal x 225 so wie es auf der karte
zwar packungsbeilage steht besser
aufpassen in zukunft joghurt minze burke
das sind die zutaten für unsere leichte
sauce die das ganze ein bisschen
abfedern soll weil kölsche töne
fleischrinder salami pizza ihr merkt
schon da geht's auf jeden fall zur sache
ist eine gurke halbieren die einmal und
schneiden jetzt solche gurken sticks
traurigkeit gut und steaks gesagt man
natürlich gucken würfels extrem
gefährlich was ich hier mache und dann
hatten wir einfach alles immer schön
keine werke mehr als die halbe gurgel
werden wir auch gar nicht brauchen muss
minze ist natürlich relativ prozent das
heißt wir nehmen nicht super viel davon
so viel mehr aber so ein bisschen rein
bzw
wir schnappen und siemens vorher und
klatschen sie einmal
man riecht ist und man schmeckt ist vor
allem dadurch wird die minze aktiviert
und trägt einfach nochmal deutlich mehr
geschmacksrichtung richtig richtigkeit
und im backofen backen unsere bank
vorsichtig waschen 20 packen schon drin
hier noch mal ein kleiner schlepper und
rhein zwischen das jetzt einfach in der
schüssel schnappen uns alles draußen ist
rein salz pfeffer dran dann haben die
wirklich schnellste oder sauce die
sieger und ich bin auch gespannt wie das
ganze gleich mit der schüssel war das
verdeck jusos harmonieren wird deshalb
heute
es wird einen gaumenschmaus ruhig ein
bisschen zu werfen beim salz alles
anderes als sehr sehr mild hier drin
wohnt fischer pfeffer ich weiß alle
sagen immer dass diese familie aussieht
wie die gta branche verstanden sind
designer möbel haben uns verstanden und
das klingt schon früh so lassen wir das
ganze jetzt auch noch ein bisschen
marinieren wenn wir alles andere machen
tom lecker so bevor wir uns jetzt um das
fleisch kümmern checken ihm einen ofen
mehr es bereuen schon langsam aber wenn
ihr mal genau hin und guckt da 12 sport
so ein bisschen käse rauskommt deshalb
auf jeden fall falls ihr das nachmachen
sollte ich meine ist ja auch ein
bisschen verrückt dieses ganze projekt
macht wirklich gut sehr gut zumal hier
die kräfte spieße dürft euch ja bekannt
seien aus einem meiner letzten videos wo
wir die von katase zubereitet bekommen
haben und dann haben wir hier drüben das
filet der straße kennen wir ja jetzt
nehmen wir das ganze und hannes auf den
grill
[Musik]
und wir schauen hier mal rein was sie
doch gut aussehen dass man nicht die
kranken bürgerbündnis je gegeben hat
weiß ich noch nicht
hu war einst komplett auskühlen
natürlich das ganze und jetzt guck dir
das an wo die post abgegangen ist leute
lieben es und das ganze gerede jetzt bis
es fertig ist wird hier schon sehr schön
knusprig wir brauchen noch ein bisschen
länger
wir zeigen euch jetzt den rest der
vorbereitung
[Musik]
was ist das für ein anblick ganz kurz
das ist nicht normal also nicht denken
man kann das essen das sind glaube ich
5000 kalorien die hier vor mir auf dem
tisch stehen aber wir machen das für die
wissenschaft und nehmen uns jetzt die
unterseite unsere ski cross capital
sogar kunden auf der unterseite salami
legen das ganze nieder und daten mit
einer guten lage soße dann poldi
dönerfleisch sind auch nicht gespart
leute wir legen dass wir richtig drauf
jetzt benötigen wir unsere tomaten weil
sie denkt momentan maximalen sind ja
umgesetzt würde niemals schon umgesetzt
tomate verwenden auf dem burger
jetzt schnappen wir uns unseren rucola
ist nehmen ist ein bisschen unsere väter
mangelnden hier so obendrüber 5000
kalorien influenza produkte börde erst
krank jetzt darf nicht fehlen kräfte
schmeckt so würzig alles nehmen
natürlich nicht ganz wir halbieren die
den sie dann auch unseren bürger zahlt
man soße und zwar kommt in die mitte
dies ist brothers barbecue sauce hat mir
die bei freddy gelegen jetzt werde vom
dreh fast leer
ok und da jetzt für den extra crunchy
rops paprika sorten leute und damit auch
das top bands schön hält gebe hier
nochmal zehn recht von unserer soße
traut ist das legal bis das legal
[Musik]
wir drücken das ganze noch ein bisschen
zusammen ich war nicht mutig genug ist
dass bisher zu machen aber ihr seht
schon dann sieht er auch noch mehr aus
wie ein echter bürger und jetzt wollte
scherte extra nochmal messer bei jetzt
kommt der große moment bin mir aber
sicher dass der rest der optiker für
mich genauso viele punkte gegeben hätte
aber das ist eine ansage
das ist pervers leute und jetzt kommen
wir zum wohl wichtigsten teil dem test
werde versuchen oh mein gott walther ist
doch nicht mehr normal
das ist wirklich nicht mehr normal aber
ich probiere es jetzt irgendwie zu
schaffen ich heute hier auch schon wie
ein schwein das ist komplett custodis
komplett kranke leute sorry dafür dass
gerade mit ansehen muss ist hat sich
zehn von zehn gelungen und und wirklich
auch diese joghurt so wichtig man
schmeckt die süße von der barbecue sauce
crunch von den chefs wirklichkeit von
kräfte und dünn haftzeit und dann noch
diese these der einfach durch die kps
pizza mit dem väter harmoniert tor
ich hoffe dass wir dadurch gefallen ich
weiß nicht ob ich das jemals auf essen
werden auf jeden fall finde ich leute
die es auch essen werden denn es ist so
gut wir sehen uns beim nächsten video
wie das macht's gut und bis dahin
schafft